mi sono scocciato la faccia l'altro
giorno in montagna quindi non mi faccio
vedere dietro perché sono veramente un
peperone quarto episodio di minecraft
parkour
buona visione ok da parte leggermente
più strana però ha spesso capito
dovrebbe essere cioè basta ok
perché se in atto tu non poteva fare
qualcos'altro
tua mamma e papà quel giorno c'è che
problemi
mio dio lo re ei che un pezzo billy
cobham e come come sei arrivato lì si
spider man
su questo bersani sulla staccionata cioè
pensate da rega non a parole si passi
una sega per che potevi avere il check
point a quest ora però vabbè ho gioito
solo per vederti cadere poi basta pasta
roba scusa è bellissimo e beli come file
di andare avanti ma come passata da una
strada una roba l'altra cammina amia
normale consiste premuto che figo tipo
freshman dico ok non usare le nuove
perché mi si è aperto il menu lo
schifoso
grazie a dio guardava l'avevo il leader
muoio
mamma mia barca vacca come ha fatto con
kit fisica ha aperto il menu dobbiamo
fare qua allora sicuramente li dovremmo
saltarci problema fare il percorso al
contrario guardiamo prima staccionate
associate qua c'è una scala però prego
prego gravissimo pimenta hai visto cosa
sono voce molto forte
ole ragazzi all e lo aspetta a no non si
può fare da qua a mi sembra troppo easy
devi fare vabbè ho capito cosa devi fare
è un macello perfetto
niente [ __ ] [ __ ] zone che sei un
fenomeno già fatta mollami mag anna dai
che è difficile che so fare qualche
nervo ma poi per un salto stupido capito
mamma mia che fastidio
ok 6 equa ok ok
yeah yeah baby no va dai fa perché ok
come fatto a morire per poche ce l'ha
fatta per fatta sei ancora di che poi ti
sto ancora provando il bravo cosa vedo
poi di raggiungere suo posto voglio
vedere con tempo ok sei entrato anche tu
qua vero si sa che non c'è un tasto per
uscire vero no dai
sai che l'unico modo per riuscire
suicidarsi vero no dai
[Musica]
ci siamo fottuti da solo l'amico era una
trappola perché divenuti 20 di dirti
questa roba che voglio vedere sempre da
solo con un deficiente aveva meno
saresti andato avanti tu porca vacca e
va da me lo meritavo
ok ok ma c'è una scala qui figurati cosa
fatto che cosa questo pessimo arrivo
anch'io dove fatto chiudere ho fatto
cose incredibili ma sulla scala si non
so come non mi chiederanno una idea ma
siccome pensare fi e non pensare tenuto
conto del fatto che tu non pensi mai non
riescono anche a capire cosa devo fare
per altro
ok capito che allora dove dove c'è poi
arrivato già da edward in realtà qua non
è necessario dopo qua intendo dopo però
attenzione dei furti
non lo rifarò mai voglio morire allora
gijsels com'è possibile che siamo
arrivati fin qua non lo so neanche io ma
va bene cos'è sta roba
ho già capito cosa devi fare e ancora
non ho visto di stare tra esatto si va
beh ma impossibile metterà tutto li
mettono proprio modo che toccata giunta
è davvero orribile matthew booth
sinistra mette al centro il more
corribile proprio guardali che bello
morire dopo di te un secondo si assicuri
che si deve fare così
assolutamente no sì stile a fare così
l'ho fatto si vabbè ma se no vabbè ma a
parte questa è la parte più difficile
fino adesso te lo giuro è fattibile sono
troppo piccoli sti cosi sono troppo
piccoli impossibile ti giuro
la sperimenta una musichetta adatto a
questo tipo di giochi ei vieni vieni che
c'è spazio per due non vedi che c'è
spazio
non c'è lo spazio eventi ce l'ho fatta
sono fortissimo pesa la fortissima
colaci aglianò non mischiare mi stai
picchiando
poi sul tetto ma dove vanno perfetto
vieni vieni vieni gira ha già girato
l'angolo
bravo iniziata bravo bravo io vado giù
questo c'è qua mi chiedo stare attento a
non prenderla l'ala perciò ho fatto sono
stato bravissimo tra l'altro non lo
saprei mai cosa ho fatto ma la cosa
bella è che l'acqua
ok ci sono la lava ha infatto brano non
morire non morire non morire vostro non
sono morto
ok perfetto da qua da qua credo che tu
debba ritornare indietro per un macello
devi fare tipo così credo ok ok e poi da
qua a volpara roba strana
questi nomi si ma per cosa sono sti cosi
tu che giochi a mike the stranger teens
un del gold provavo buttati vedere come
si fila fortissimo vai vai bravissimo
bravissimo tutto nel cap aspetti come
negativo al check point
eccole qua e qua qua qua e qua lo
presenti poche a vedi che ci sono i
corsi sulle è bravo esatto bravo e laura
equa non lo so c'è una scala la vedi si
è mai visto vero affetto
cos'è che bello qua carino ma ste
stupidi malfattori tornato vero prima
torniamo dov'eravamo prima qua come
sperone possibile o no
non capisco e anch'io aspettami scendo
un attimo ed ora un primo sì che tanto
ci poteva arrivare ma no ma da allora
non dispongono ancora pinto dello giuro
non so cosa bisogna fare ok ho capito
porca vacca maiorca che casino c'è
figurati ma è così facendo si fa come
cosa ci provo è ok ci sono già arrivato
il primo buco perfetto perfetto guardali
guardali guardate già fatta ce l'ho
fatta poi ucciderti
ok di sly non sa ancora dove highly ecco
infatti non capivo ok no dai perché
faccio le cose difficili le cagate non
le faccio ok lo oggi cos'è un fenomeno
oggi un fenomeno legato da qua è un
casino tutto però non spieghi perché non
riesco a fare questo problema non è fa
non è poco facilissimo da qua un macello
lucrativo porca vacca 9 da parte qua
sopra è veramente difficile credere qua
come fai scusami
io ce l'ho fatta e da qua aiuto qui
sopra l'area ma tu sei scemo ma come
fare anche tra mille anni arrivò lima
separa ragazza su un airone ma va ma si
scemo come mi chiama ci sono delle
dell'islam sott'acqua
cosa aspetta ma vedi che gesù c'è però
non mi aiuta perché era già fatto e su
quanto già fatta giungere a te lo giuro
io col cavolo che sono qui vedo qua con
il coni di nuovo se sei non ti vedo
neanche non mi trova per vederlo adesso
ti vedo vai vai statali a sei già il
punto bravo colucci per me ride man 2 6
io sono saprebbero ok saba v della mano
e vieni vieni che ti dà una mano
no e non funziona e ci ho provato a ya
no no no no no no che sì è caduto
ammazzo io bensì una roba qua io ho
fatto praticamente fatto
qual è livello yeah non vedo neanche
dove c'è poco da prendere che poi prende
adesso ci prova un attimo credo di
riuscirci aspetta
guardali che progaming guardali che
problemi guardali progaming guarda il
problemi guardalo progaming il pro gamer
sporca eva che schifo e aspetta che
aprendosi a quanti filati fidatevi fatto
può accadere
ok poi ecco lo aspetta quadra casinò non
ho quasi una idea di cosa stia facendo
saltare
grazie prego madonna
no perché per un metro
neanche la 2 centimetri da allora
ragazzuoli e vado quanto siamo in alto 6
che siamo in altissimo c'è veramente ho
fatto il tumore che ho fatto tanto che
ho fatto un chilometro di roba da oggi
cosa c'è oggi
cosa c'è oggi e sono un deficiente o
perfetto fatta ok ok ok ci sono le sei
tu qua sotto mico è quella della parte
incasinati nonno brava brava brava con
shift by all'angolo così bella ciao
ok let's go baby let's go per social
point ma c'è una cascata sali che carino
da parte
vabbè che difficile ok no guardalo a chi
oggi è tanta roba a pensare proprio
diritura sopra mini quad show io arrivo
arrivo no dài dài porca vacca dai pur
kakà ce l'ho fatta ma che salti
incredibili ha fatto fare quindi ragazzi
spero che vi sia piaciuto come al solito
sul video è piaciuto lasciato momento mi
piace anche varisco mila donne schizzare
sostenere si chiede e noi ci vediamo
professioni da ragazzi
[Musica]